I'll just got ahead and admit it:  I am starving for female friendship.
I know that might not sound that embarrassing but on the inside it feels like
Be my friend!
And I feel like I'm single in dating because every time I meet a really cool chick
I'm like
Hey I would love to take you out to dinner and a movie
You know?  Just so we can get to know each other better
maybe just hang out, learn a little bit about each other
develop a life long friendship and carry on that friendship until death do us part you know,
You know.  Nothing big, nothing big.
And it's not like I don't have friends, you know.  I do.
It's just that I don't have a best friend.
I'm late to the party.  Everyone in LA knows each other from college
or from an old work and here I am arriving late, looking for somebody to pair up with.
(Singing) Hello from the other side!
And as an adult, friendships are work.
You know, everyone is pursuing their career or relationships so getting together
is something that you have to actively pursue.
It's not like High School where we were all forced to be in this prison together everyday.
Now, you have to make plans.
Which can be tough.
There's this one girl that I really like and I want to be better friends with
but I started noticing that it was always me initiating our hangouts
so I've kinda been refraining from "asking her out"
so I can finally see if she will invite me somewhere
cause friendships should be mutual, you know?  We should want to hang out with each other.
Are you sure you want to hang out?
(muffled) Yeah!  Yeah!
Are you positive?
(muffled) Yes! I totally want to hang out!
But what about you?  Do you struggle with friendships or are you the type of person that just
makes and keeps friends easily?
Do you have a best friend?  Or...are you looking for one?
I'm available!
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay awesome Gotham.
Thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring today's episode!
You, my mortal friend, can go to Squarespace.com and start building your website today!
The sites all look professionally designed regardless of your skill level
and the tools are intuitive and easy to use.
The best part is, it's only $8 a month and you get a free domain if you sign up for a year.
Use the offer code "Anna" for 10% off at checkout
(chuckles)
Start your free trial now with no credit card required.
Squarespace.  Build it beautiful.
Hey guys!  GhostsandStars.com has brand new leggings!
Catstronaut and Galaxy!  They are the perfect Christmas gifts so check it out at GhostandStars.com.
Also!  I have a bunch of lives shows coming out
you can find out more information at AnnaAkana.com about where they're at, how to get tickets and
I always do a meet and greet.
Finally, Explain Things To Me (My podcast on iTunes)
has some amazing new guests!  We've got a taxidermist, a medical examiner, paleontologist
quantum physicist--all these cool people coming up
so don't forget to go to iTunes and check it out.
That's it.  Whew!